Another question. One is a red arrow pointing up or down indicate, and I think this person
is asking on the genetic report. So I actually took a screenshot of what I think they're
talking about this red arrow pointing down in this case, and it's on the gene that I just
talked about, the HNMT gene. That means it's down-regulated or up-regulated, meaning if
there's a, they're talking about how you should deal with it. This, in this case, it means
down-regulated, and I'm up there if that's what the arrow is going on. But if, in, so
in this case, what would be going on if it was down-regulated, meaning if you have defects
on that gene, typically it means that gene is down-regulated. Let me explain that a little
for those who don't understand full medical terminology. So if I have defects on a gene,
so on this gene, HNMT gene, let's say I had a double allele defect on these genes,
that would tell us that from all the literature, if you have defects on that gene, that gene is
down-regulated, meaning that that means the gene doesn't work as well, and you could have issues
with what that gene does. Now, in this case, the HNMT gene makes the DAO enzyme in the tissue
to break down histamine. So if I had defects on this gene, I'm not going to make that as well.
There are some genes that, with defects, causes an up-regulation of that gene. So that's where
the difference of that is. So if there's an up-regulation of the gene, typically with a defect,
that's a totally different story. So, and different people can't have different issues with that too,
but typically that's what the program is telling us is that in all the literature,
defects on that gene tend to be down-regulation, or tend to be up-regulation. That's what those
are.